[Music]
[Applause]
is the journalist with us Todd any
minute okay Eric name the senior writer
for the athletic he covers the bucks he
was there when all the drama unfolded in
the bowels of the stadium the arena
there let's bring in Eric who joins us
on the program help me understand here
uh okay is it Giannis who wanted the
ball for Giannis or did jannis wanted
for Dame
Lillard I mean I think Giannis wanted it
for Giannis I think when Giannis had a
chance to talk about it a little bit he
also wanted it for Dame because he
realized you know I have a a Hall of
Fame teammate with me he just had a
historic night as well so we need that
game ball as well uh but no I think more
than anything Giannis knew that that was
a franchise record one that he one of
the few franchise records at this point
that he doesn't have uh he wanted that
basketball he didn't have it and he
needed to go chase it down how much of a
factor was it that it was the Pacers and
the Bucks given what happened with the
inseason tournament
game I think the the Bucks definitely
wanted to get that game back last night
the they've lost twice to the Pacers
this year the first game this year
Yannis had 54 points uh and the Pacers
were still able to come back from behind
and and grab a win there so uh I don't
think the Bucks enjoy playing the Pacers
all that much I don't think they enjoyed
the Pacers uh you know having some fun
at the Bucs expense in the inseason
tournament you know tyres halberton is
is fantastic but he did the whole you
know fake Dame time kind of thing is it
my time now instead of Dame time and you
could kind of see that from the start of
the game like at at the very start of
this game Giannis gets a attack he he
delivers a forearm shiver to tyres
Halton as halton's going back up the
floor so you can tell there's this kind
of bad blood I don't want to call it a
rivalry quite yet they haven't played
playoff games like the Bucs have act
like fullon playoff rivalry with like a
team like the heat so it's not quite
there yet but yeah it definitely has
some of that they're a little bit
annoyed with with the little brother
here kind of trying to you know start
something with the big brother where is
the game
ball I mean that all depends who you ask
uh
because after the game like I'm sitting
in the locker room and Giannis is a th%
convinced that the ball that is in his
possession sitting next to his locker is
not the game ball from last night
because every game I I mean I learned a
lot about game balls in NBA rules last
night but before every game there's
three balls so you have three balls out
there the captains go out they pick one
of them and then there's a reserve game
ball but also for my understanding there
should be a reserve to the Reserve game
ball so there should be three that are
there uh so Giannis thinks the ball that
was put in front of him in the locker
room after the game is the reserved game
ball and not the actual game ball and
his reasoning was I played 37 minutes I
felt the ball throughout the night I
shot 32 free throws I know what it feels
like that is not what the ball feels
like so while they are telling him this
is the game ball and you can watch you
know uh right after the game the one of
the buck security guards goes straight
to the ref grabs the ball
and from what I can tell gives it to
someone that works for the bucks and
then the Bucks have the ball in their
possession but 20 seconds later tyres
hurn has a ball in his hands jannis sees
it and thinks that's the ball so
honestly it it is all about who you
believe at this point because there are
number of people that I guess can
account for the ball for some portion of
the night but can't account for the ball
for other portions of the night and now
it is just who you believe and this is
one of the more ridiculous things I've
ever covered in my time covering the
League worst look for the Pacers or
Giannis oh that's interesting um I mean
probably Giannis like he is someone
that's accomplished a lot he's been
through a lot at this point he should
probably you know not allowing teams to
kind of get underneath his skin uh in
this way but at the same time you know
whether or not the Pacers had the actual
ball once they're in the tunnel they are
yelling back to Giannis and all the
Bucks players that have come along with
them don't let him have the ball you're
not getting the ball so they enjoyed
that you know whether or not they had it
they enjoyed that Giannis thought that
they had it so again I I don't know that
anyone really comes up looking uh
looking great after this one cuz it
truly is a pretty ridiculous situation
okay did you do any reporting on the
Pacers with their tradition that their
rookies when they score their first
basket they get the ball yeah so that is
something that they do but because this
story just just keeps having more and
more layers it gets even more confusing
because Oscar sheway technically scored
before last tonight against the Lakers
right but he did so in the inseason
tournament so now we have to figure out
is that an actual point because we're
not sure how anyone's going to keep
these records going forward because one
we don't know if the inseason tournament
is going to exist going forward we don't
know how long it's going to exist going
forward we don't know if it was an
actual game or a not actual game or just
an inseason Tournament game so what's in
an official NBA point at this at this
point What's an official NBA ball at
this point which one's the real one
which one's the fake one none of us know
know anything Dan that's all I know at
this point this is what I'm wondering
you know now as we move on when a rookie
scores his first points does he ask to
stop the game so he can take the ball
out of the game so he does there's no
confusion in case somebody goes for you
know 72 points in a game I mean honestly
let let's just go MLB style and you know
after after every timeout we'll get a
new ball in there we'll scuff it up
we'll make sure that's okay this is a
free throw you grab it throw it back out
get a new ball in there like well let's
just go for it Dan do you think Giannis
gets
fined yeah I think so I I don't think
you can have the situation where you
know you're running into a tunnel and
making the scene you know when you were
talking to Rick car after the game he
mentioned that uh Pacers GM chabu Canan
was in the tunnel and ended up getting
bumped during that uh chabu Canan
confirmed with everyone that he's F and
I don't think it's going to be a serious
injury but again just the the look of it
all
a a general manager kind of getting
into it's not a scuffle but whatever you
know some sort of physical
altercation uh with a player like yeah
there's there's probably a fine coming
can't wait until they meet what January
1 in Indiana I mean the beauty of it is
it's January 1 in Milwaukee and then
January 3rd in Indiana a home in home
just I mean it's going to be lovely 48
hours all the Rival can be renewed and
we can figure it out all all over again
I can't I truly can't wait thank you
Eric we appreciate your time I'm sorry I
have no answers at
all neither do we Eric neither do we
Eric name the senior writer for the
athletic covering the Bucks yeah nobody
ever said we had answers either I ask
questions I don't have any answers
that's a good appearance by him